hello
all you creatures of the internet
the world wide web the thing
how you doing people it is november 23rd
2020 monday november 23rd 2020. i'm dave
rubin i'm feeling very refreshed had a
nice weekend didn't pay too much
attention to politics i am caffeinated i
had some water
a few people said last week that i
looked a little parched
uh that i should have more water that i
had paused a couple times
because my mouth seemed dry so i have
plenty of water here
and i've got my coffee i think it's a
coffee related thing
but i'm in a good mood uh there's a lot
going on obviously it's a bit of a short
week because of thanksgiving and i
i will be celebrating thanksgiving i
hope you will be celebrating
thanksgiving i hope you'll be with
friends and family and everything else
we will be um we're going to fight the
power over here at the uh the dave rubin
compound
um there's a lot going on you're not
going to believe it guys there's there's
really a lot going on right now so we're
going to recap and you know every week
we go from one bananas thing to a
bonkers thing to a crazy thing and
everything else
well it all sort of feels like it's
coming to a head as we enter
the end of 2020 right because you know
we've got coronavirus
covid whatever you want to call it at
this point everyone is
is in some version of lockdown we have
people rising up and fighting it
we have these authoritarian governors
and mayors trying to keep us in our
houses
so that's really been ramped up and then
of course there's everything going on
with
the election joe biden says he's the
president-elect
that's not official obviously that's
just by media projections trump is not
conceding anything then there was some
weirdness so this is going to be the
first story we're going to cover today
is the weirdness going on
with sydney powell who had some
interesting things to say over the
weekend and then suddenly the trump
campaign
distanced themselves from her so we're
going to
talk about that first then i want to
talk about uh some covid stuff and i'm
going to show you two
really really spectacular
videos one from buffalo where business
owners have just had it and they are
actually kicking regulators out and it's
a really beautiful moment like it's a
it's a tea
party style moment from buffalo new york
i'm gonna show you that
and then another video from jersey this
past weekend where
uh some citizens of the great state of
new jersey saw their governor
at a restaurant now he's keeping
everybody else in lockdown now
technically you can be at a restaurant
but they were not having it and uh and
it's pretty great and there's a there's
a jersey
feel to it with with some of the
language that you're only going to get
out of jersey
uh and then finally i want to show you
this video
from i i suppose a comedian named amber
ruffin
i did not know who she was until a
couple days ago but i was flipping on
the uh on the twitter there
and i saw a video that was in my
timeline i don't follow her but it was
promoted
from the peacock network and the peacock
network is nbc's new streaming
site and i saw this this really
really awful crazy video
that well let's just let's just leave it
at that just
stick with me for 15 20 minutes and
we'll get to it in a little bit
but it's it's just the worst sort of
intersectional lunacy and social justice
nonsense
being pushed by by mainstream
corporations
in the name of tolerance and diversity
and it's just not that okay
but let's start with what's going on
with the election right now so i have
said from the beginning and i would
welcome any
of my critics to watch any of my videos
over the last couple weeks i've said
from the beginning
that you can't take anyone's word for
any of this if trump just
says it was rigged you can't take his
word for it and you can't take any
lawyer's word for anything and you can't
take the mainstream media's
uh word for it when they say nothing was
rigged and nothing happened and don't
look here right everybody's credibility
is sort of shot so the only thing that
you can do in a time like that
is try to go to where the facts are and
that's exactly what i've been trying to
say this whole time that it's one thing
for sydney powell and trump and
and whoever on any side of this to say
we know about fraud we know about this
we know about that
well at some point you've got to show us
the evidence by the way i've also been
saying this entire time
that you don't just leak out evidence
you know a lot of people
were angry at tucker carlson last week
because it seemed like he was saying
well sydney powell doesn't have
evidence and really what i was my
defense of tucker
it was a defensive tucker and sydney
actually which was you don't
leak things out or imagine imagine if
you had a murder case next week
right you got a murder case that you're
trying seven days from now would you
suddenly be telling the media and the
other legal side and everything else oh
well you know we did find this knife
here and this guy told us this
no you'd wait till you were in court now
we're in a weird time these days where
where lawyers are always doing things on
television and obviously there's a
certain magnifying
glass on this because it's the election
um
but in essence tucker was saying well
she didn't provide any evidence
and sidney powell was saying well
actually we offered you some
some testimony and some affidavits which
they didn't want to air but i think what
really happened there
was that if anything tucker was trying
to to set up something right like
basically he was like okay we have her
on but we
can't uh or we're going to talk about
the story but in essence we can't
confirm this until there's evidence
which
is the truth that's exactly what i've
been saying so now i'm going to show you
two things here
because there was a really uh
interesting twist of events
this weekend so first off sydney powell
who was
was is the key word here uh until the
last 24 hours basically
was on the trump legal team
she was on newsmax tv talking about
what she's got so let's take a look at
the clip and then we'll go from there
how what is your timeline as you look at
this you know what's the timeline you
think before you can you can put out
some of this evidence that can really
you know if you want to if you want to
shut the media up but they say that you
guys have nothing
when will you have some of this stuff
that's that's this hardcore evidence and
paper in writing
well frankly the affidavits we've
already introduced are hardcore evidence
their firsthand testimony of witnesses
who saw
how and why the system was created and
how it worked to accomplish the
objective for hugo chavez
they're people who saw ballots being
destroyed we've got evidence from people
who saw
fake ballots being created we've got all
kinds of different evidence
and then we've got the statistical and
mathematical evidence that's
absolutely irrefutable i mean a coin
doesn't land on the same
side when you flip it 186 000 times you
can't just
inject 86 000 biden votes and expect
anybody to believe those are real
and they're not when we see no matter
how you analyze the statistics whether
it's a predictive model or the actual
data as it comes in it doesn't hold
water
and we've got other testimonial evidence
that appears to be coming in now to
indicate the democrats
literally added 35 000 votes
to every democratic candidate to begin
with
35 in in any particular state or you say
35 000 where
we've got it definitely all over one
state and
i would be willing to bet it happened
everywhere
okay so as i've said many times you
can't just
take sydney powell's word for it right
you just can't take that but she's
laying out some very specific things
she's saying we have first-hand
testimony
she's saying that they they saw ballots
destroyed and then she's also talking
about the
statistical evidence hey connor i'm
getting a little feedback here if you
can just cut that for me thanks
um so okay so she's laying something out
but you again you can't just take her
word for it but she's saying this is
what we have and this is what we're
gonna present to the courts now that was
this weekend and then
yesterday things got a little stranger
because suddenly rudy giuliani who's
heading
the trump legal team he put out a
statement so let's
let's read the statement here quote
sydney powell
is practicing law on her own she is not
a member of the trump legal team
she is also not a lawyer for the
president in his personal capacity
okay so now this gets really interesting
because
we showed the clip but she was at the
press conference with giuliani and jenna
ellis the other two lawyers
that involved her at least on the public
side she was at the press conference
last week
so something happened in the midst of
this now i saw a whole bunch of people
saying all sorts of stuff
over the last little bit people are
saying well sydney powell is obviously
insane she's a conspiracy theorist and
blah blah
now i still just don't buy that i don't
buy that this woman is just lighting
herself
on fire and has gone completely crazy i
suspect that she has some of the
evidence that she's talking about
and she's going to try to lay it out in
court okay whether
whether that will be enough to prove
anything or anything else separate issue
but i saw a lot of people saying that
what strikes what seems to me
to be a more honest explanation or at
least a more clear thinking explanation
what's going on here is
that there may be reasons
that trump can't have sydney powell on
the
the legal side of this because she's
pursuing other things that seem more
related to the voting systems than
dominion and everything else
while giuliani and jen ellis they're
dealing with things at the state level
and they're dealing
with things related to dates that
ballots came in
and everything else there may just be
some strategic legal move there
this is one of these things where
everyone pretends they're an expert in
all of this
i'm not an expert in all of this i but i
think i'm a
pretty decent uh explainer of just sort
of
human nature and again as i've said from
the beginning either sidney powell is
about to drop the biggest
bombshell in modern political times if
not in the last 200 years
or she's about to destroy herself the
jew the
trump campaign separating themselves
from that i don't think is just like oh
that woman is bananas we don't want
anything to do with her anymore
i think that there may be some legal
reason for that now again
and i'll just say one more time for
today and then i'll move on that doesn't
mean that anything
she said here is true in and of itself
and you can't believe it just because
she said it but she's telling you
about that she has first-hand testimony
she's telling you about sworn affidavits
she was talking about people that were
there when they set
up the voting systems and all that so
we shall see is sort of where we're at
with all that but i saw all these people
like oh the whole thing's over and the
infighting and all that and it's like i
don't know
i do want to say one other thing on this
which is that i am getting a tremendous
amount of pushback uh in some cases from
public people that have been on my show
for even discussing any of this stuff
as if this stuff should not be discussed
at all now i'm giving you some basic
info here you know we do this show
usually in about 24 minutes i'm not
trying to to beat you over the head with
this
i'm not trying to make you a conspiracy
conspiracy theorist
and i'm not trying to make you crazy but
when the mainstream media won't even
give you
any honest assessment of what might be
going on here
and i saw suddenly all these mainstream
people saying oh see
it's obvious sydney powell's gone crazy
even
crazy giuliani won't won't uh defend her
won't backer anymore and it's like that
that's not
news analysis right so i think i've
given you some sort of basic news
analysis here which is that you don't
trust the words in and of themselves but
but the the split that we're seeing here
there may be a reason for it
and if there isn't if we find out that
that ultimately and
by the way it'll all come out one way or
another like in a year from now
this whole thing falls apart and
giuliani's like yeah i thought she was
bananas and that's why we got her off
the team well then that would be worth
talking about but but analyzing it as we
get it now
there's nothing wrong with talking about
that stuff and i'm seeing a lot of
people
that just don't want us to talk about
any of these things don't give it any
air because it's all so crazy
and it's just like that that's not how
i'm gonna behave i'm just not gonna
behave that way and speaking of how i'm
not gonna behave
i will also be having thanksgiving oh
and by the way i was out
on the streets this weekend in l.a on
saturday night after 10 p.m which i'm
pretty sure we weren't allowed to do you
know we
we put these new orders edicts whatever
you want to call these stupid things
from our ridiculous
mayor governor gavin newsom in
california he can't be out after 10 p.m
i mean just just
absolute authoritarian dribble well this
is happening all over the country
people have had it with the lockdowns
now again we know that covid cases are
going up our
deaths going up that's not that's not
what i'm seeing um
we know that 97.5 to 99
of people survive cobit and the people
that don't usually have several other
medical complications
and they're usually uh elderly people
meaning over the age of 80 roughly
but we've decided to wreck our economy
just shut down everything destroy
livelihoods
pin people into lives of depression and
alcoholism and drug abuse and
all sorts of terrible things well the
people have had it and i for one am on
the side of the people
that you have to make some decisions in
your own life as you guys know so i'm
going to show you two videos here and
they're both pretty spectacular the
first one is just
is just remarkable so this is out of
buffalo new york where the buffalo wing
was invented
and i've spent a little time in buffalo
over the years it's chilly but it's a
great town
and watch what happened here when
government regulators i mean these are
the middlemen right these are just the
foot soldiers of these people
who put out these crazy regulations in
the case of new york andrew cuomo the
governor
let's see what happens when health
department officials and the sheriff
show up at a local business in buffalo
new york these people actually work for
their money
and they don't want to lose their
livelihood i've lost friends
who've killed themselves i've seen
clients die because they've lost their
livelihood
i'm sorry to hear that i know you are
and i'm just i'm asking for you to guys
have some compassion
for the people that have lost everything
we do have compassion for
people okay well you need to go have
compassion out in the parking lot this
is private property
this is this is private property this is
private property
it's private property listen man this is
private property they're not wanted here
so do your jobs well her job is well no
no your job is to remove people that are
not wanted here you have a school
they're not she's hiding your name she
got it i'm not it's right now
it's my turn they're just
don't worry about my health my health
isn't your concern you're meant to be
wearing a mosque
okay well then write me up it's the law
okay then but then take me to jail
not the law and take me to jail
you have to leave now you're trespassing
without a warranty
yes you do come back with the warrant or
don't write the laws
inside no go on your phone go on your
phone outside
you know what i don't know yeah it's
anonymous right it's anonymous that
can't be anonymous
you need to know you're accusing me
you gotta go get a warranty
you don't get to violate the
constitution it does not
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
man ladies and gentlemen that right
there
is what america is all about i am i am
proud like i have a feeling of pride
while watching that video that is what
it is all about
standing up to authoritarian governments
and middle management people who have
never created
anything and who are trying to control
you
there's some beautiful lines in there so
first off one of the guys that comes in
says they're just doing their job
they're just doing their job as if
they're not the bad guys right they're
just doing their job
you know you know what the nazis used to
say when they would put nazis on trial
the nuremberg trials and and after the
holocaust after world war ii they would
put nazis on trial and almost everybody
would say i was just following orders
doesn't that sound an awful lot like oh
i'm just doing my
job he's just doing his job that that is
how
evil spreads evil doesn't spread because
everyone suddenly becomes evil evil
spreads because
people good people just stop thinking
good people just start turning on their
neighbors good people
start thinking that they should have
power over other people so
so these people who stood up to defend
their business
i i don't know their names maybe we can
find out a little bit more
but these are true american heroes these
are patriots
and what this was making me think and
they got rid of them like they got them
out of there
and and basically those regulators i'm
not even saying they're bad people
they're just people who aren't
thinking and they're just doing their
job their job of nothingness
and by the way the beautiful thing when
the owner there at the beginning was
saying this thing
about um about people have died
well it's it's beautiful because he's
trying to show you
the the human cost of this nonsense
people are dying because of lockdown
people are depressed
people are angry people are scared we're
breaking we're breaking
social human moments and we have to
fight that the beauty of that is that we
need to start talking about it we need
to start
pushing back against these these
mid-management these are people who have
accomplished nothing and who will never
accomplish anything
and they're they're using the power of
the government to come in
and stop good people who have built
things created things restaurants and
stores and jobs and businesses and
livelihoods
we're letting them come in and and
basically try to stop them from doing
that tell them
i'm nobody that's ever done anything but
i'm going to tell you how to live your
life
and americans are pushing back and and
it really is a beautiful thing and it
was making me think you know maybe
maybe what the next version of the tea
party is you know i'm talking about
the the original tea party no taxation
without representation well maybe
it won't be a massive worldwide
or nationwide move maybe it won't be
that but maybe it will be these
little tea parties these little parties
that we will start springing up
in all of these different little cities
where people will stand up for
themselves we've seen business
people in brooklyn do it now we're
seeing it in buffalo we've seen it
in texas we've seen it in tennessee
where people will say no more of this
and the only way that this thing has
power
is if we all give it power so even here
in los angeles
the sheriffs were saying that they
weren't going to back
gavin newsom's order to lock people in
their homes at 10 p.m like
that's how we fight back these people
only have power
over us if we grant them that power if
we give them that power so that
that's a little beautiful thing there
and i hope that these sort of micro tea
parties
just keep stopping up or just keep
happening and and what would be
beautiful about that is it gives you the
power back then you decide
what you want to happen in your home and
in your business and at your school in
your local
community imagine that personal
responsibility i know i know i'm just
crazy
uh okay so let's show you another video
now i have to warn you here people
there's gonna be an f-bomb or two
because this comes straight out of
jersey
okay and everything about this video is
why i freaking love new jersey
it's why i love the sopranos
it's why i love the northeast and all of
that stuff
so the this is a woman taking this video
she
saw the governor of new jersey at a
restaurant
and i will unpack it a bit afterwards
because
uh you know i don't like the idea of
people assaulting people
while they're at restaurants right we've
played videos of this where people are
screaming at people and
actually acting violently and throwing
things at them and firecrackers and all
sorts of stuff so you should never do
anything violently
uh that goes without saying uh but i do
think there is a difference between
uh telling a public official what what
you want to say to them versus doing it
to a random private citizen who's
you know just out out to dinner in any
event uh let's
watch this video from this weekend over
in new jersey
oh my gosh hey how you doing how are you
doing such a dick
you're having fun with your family in
the meantime you're having all kind of
other [ __ ] going on
here no no i'm not drunk
as a matter of fact you can go [ __ ]
yourself how's that
you know why i don't need a mask because
there ain't nothing like [ __ ]
stronger i like your trump
[ __ ] right guess who trump likes he
likes my daughter yeah he does no
he doesn't like yourself
thank you
i did warn you about some colorful
language there like that to me is like
just such a great example of new jersey
and like people standing up for
themselves now first off okay let's be
clear
so patrick murphy is the is the governor
of new jersey now they've had all sorts
of
crazy lockdowns on the rest of it so
technically
technically what he's doing there was
not breaking his own laws
and his own regulations because he was
sitting at a table so
had so i i believe you are allowed to
sit at a table that's why these
restaurants are open right
now the funny part is he obviously
starts feeling guilty by the end because
then he puts the mask on but he's
sitting with his family at a table
there's no reason
to wear the mask now colorful language
aside like i just
love the like balls on that woman right
like just
just you are not better than me you are
not better than me i'm going to say what
i'm going to say what i want to say
right um you're such a dick
that's what she says it's kind of great
and then what appears to be his son is
like oh no my dad loves trump my dad
loves trump he's like
come on this is all this is also stupid
but then so the family members start
putting
the masks on as if they've done
something wrong but i
by his own regulations i suppose that
they haven't
now look i don't like the idea of people
verbally going after people at
restaurants and at public places and all
of those things and i've talked about
why we can't
have that like it will it will unfurl
the bonds of society if we're just
constantly
assaulting people verbally certainly
physically and everything else
i do think there's a little bit of a
difference when it's a public person
who's putting these things
so might it have been better if these
women had politely walked up and said oh
you know governor murphy
uh we're citizens of new jersey and
we're really not happy with the
lockdowns blah blah blah
yeah it might have been wouldn't have
gone as viral and
you know these are these are jersey
ladies and and you got to love them for
it
but again this is what i mean by the
sort of micro tea party version of this
stuff
people are being brave these are the
types of video you're not going to see
that buffalo video on cnn you're not
going to see
this jersey video on cnn if anything
maybe
that that humpty dumpty buffoon brian
stelter will show this video to sort of
imply that
that you know jersey people and trump
supporters are all racist white
supremacists or something
because they would edit it in a weird
way uh but i just think it's important
to show you guys these things so that
you feel a little more courage
in your own life to to stand up for
whatever you believe in as
as i always say even if it's not what i
believe in um okay
gonna do one more for you because i
thought this was just sort of
a perfect example of how crazy
everything is
and how when we talk about why social
justice is wrong and intersectionality
is wrong
and everybody's a nazi is wrong and
trump supporters all racist
is wrong when we talk about these things
these aren't just like micro things
these are actually really
macro things that are being embedded
into society at the highest levels
so over the weekend uh i was flipping
around on my phone for a few minutes
and i saw a promoted tweet i saw a
promoted tweet by
peacock tv which is nbc's new streaming
network i don't have it i've never seen
it
but they're obviously putting money into
it they've started a digital network
right that
that's great they started their own
digital network and they're financially
promoting things that's how it got into
my timeline
and i saw this video uh of a comedian i
suppose she's a comedian i've never
heard of her before and
as you'll see i don't think there's much
comedy going on here uh but a comedian
by the name of amber ruffin i have
nothing against
her actually but i am going to show you
this clip and then
we're going to unpack it a little bit
and you see you let me know
if you think something is wrong with
this so this is a clip
from the amber ruffin show talking about
what you should do
this thanksgiving ever since the
election there's been a lot of talk in
the media online and
maybe even in your white family's group
chat about how it's a time to reach out
to republicans who are upset about the
election
about how it's important to build
bridges to trump supporters and
to find common ground with them and i
just wanted to let each and every person
out there know that you
100 percent absolutely do not have to do
that
in all honesty i would suggest you don't
and here's why
trump supporters are racist and if you
create a space for racists
to thrive they will and is that
something you want
truly can cindy come over to your house
and be like yuck
mexicans because if so you are providing
a safe
place for her racism to flourish don't
be like that
giving a racist your time and energy is
like giving a seed water and light it
helps them grow into a flower
but not a normal flower one of those
terrifying flowers from little shop of
horrors
you don't owe them anything especially
forgiveness because
it's okay if you don't forgive them for
what they've done separating families
empowering white supremacists bringing
back kid rock
your sympathy and empathy are important
and necessary gifts but
you don't have to give those gifts away
at the expense of your humanity
it is not a white elephant party with
your office
it's a red elephant party and all of
their gifts are bad and hate black
people
so if you needed someone to tell you
this here goes
you do not have to go to their weddings
and you do not have to invite them to
yours
your uncle isn't weird weird uncles have
eye patches and tell ghost stories
your uncle is a racist and if he has an
eye patch
you have a weird uncle who is also a
racist
and whenever we can have thanksgiving
together again you don't have to go
and if you do go you can tell everybody
that uncle patchy ain't [ __ ]
now to be clear i'm not saying anything
radical
i'm not saying burn it down
yet but really i'm not saying cuss
everyone out i'm just saying
you don't have to be sweet to everyone
kindness is your gift to dole out as you
see
fit and i really want you to hear this
searching for the good in someone who
thinks nothing of you
is how they condition us to become
accustomed to being treated like [ __ ]
don't become accustomed to being treated
like [ __ ]
you don't have to be nice to trump
supporters you don't have to find ways
to get close to them in fact you
shouldn't get close to them because
they're probably not wearing a mask
they deserve to lose and they lost and
they're allowed to be sad but
you're allowed to laugh at them because
after all the things they did to
us this [ __ ] is funny as hell
okay i'd like to declare here on
november 23rd 2020 that comedy is
officially dead
because there was nothing funny there it
was actually kind of scary
and gross and now i want to be clear i
don't know
amber ruffin i had never heard of amber
ruffin before this the only reason i'm
playing this clip
is because nbc which is a giant
corporation that has a lot of influence
and a lot of control over your lives
the messaging that you hear in news and
in entertainment and everything else
they're putting money behind that like
major money
behind that show i guarantee you that
whatever the budget
is for that show for a year that is
significantly more than the budget is
for this show that i run here
okay now that's well and good and i'm
not controlled by anybody and that's
wonderful
but the point is that giant corporations
in a weird way
have now decided that hating people it's
not just calling everybody racist but
that was
hate like that was all that in effect if
you want to talk about hate speech
congratulations you got it right there
because she's telling you to hate half
the country and it's and it's just
awful so you know what i did i rewrote
that speech just a bit of it i
paraphrased it and
made it a little more succinct and and
did it the way that i would do it and
i'll leave it up to you guys
to decide which one is better which one
is
a more effective way for us to live in a
pluralistic free society so
i'm gonna do this and then i'm gonna say
goodbye to you so here we go
this is me making amber ruffin's speech
decent crazy ever since the election
there's been a lot of talk in the media
online and maybe even in your family's
group chat about how it's time to reach
out
to republicans who are upset about the
election about how it's important to
build bridges to trump supporters and to
find common ground with them
and i just wanted to let each and every
person out there
know that you 100 absolutely
should do that in all honesty i would
suggest
you do because trump supporters are not
racist
if you do so you are providing a safe
place
for unity to flourish give your family
time and energy forgive one another for
what they've
done sympathy and empathy are important
and you should give them away so if you
needed someone to tell you this
here it goes you should go to
thanksgiving
with family members that you disagree
with you should go to their weddings
and you need to invite them to yours
your weird uncle is not a racist
i'm not saying anything radical here and
happy thanksgiving
all right guys i hope you see that that
message
is something that nbc maybe should be
pushing but i have no
hope for nbc but the point is understand
who the people are that want tolerance
and diversity and
who are the people that just trade in it
as part of their grift i think you can
see what's what
uh reminder guys we just put up part one
of my interview with comedian nicole
arbour she is
absolutely freaking spectacular
if you have not seen it check it out
she's just great the full episode is
already up
at reubenreport.com she's an actually
funny comedian like if you think
that that this ruffin chick was awful
like you want to see what comedy really
is nicole arbour is it
check out part one and as i said the
full part on reubenreport.com don't
forget to subscribe right here on
youtube
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
you